Oh Randolph wicked welcome everybody  tonight we are proud to present three  plays ladies and gentlemen be bad for  how many more times really haven't you  got someone else to mother I'm sorry go  back to the woods tried it your way  really yeah just thought you do  [Music]  money I'm not a cheeky number Fox you  know I am the big bad Fox great he's  gonna read I doubt it he's fixing  himself a snack I tried your chicks  tried to bite Cuba's let's go to them  they'd like to eat my little [ __ ] I  don't know what if we become responsible  adults this is our self-defense pops  extermination mommy's going to deal with  this gentleman who is looking after  Michelle I can take them for you no no  no no I would above you at all  [Music]